qui était présente à
moi j'ai quelque chose
c'est lourd encore
ça va aller remplir
panneaux bio
c'est chercher
c'est bien ça attendu à huy
est probable
aussi vient ça vient c'est le truc à
canon mais c'est un coup ouais c'est les
pistolets en quoi les 22 long rifle pour
la précision pistolets de salon ouais
c'est un pistolet de salon wololo ta
catégorie des incroyables ah ça c'est
super beau et bon bravo ça c'est 1850
environ très sympa et super jolie et je
pense que sa part en resto ouais on peut
essayer
des fois on trouve des armes on est à
apurer l'état qu'est ce que je fais
police me police
il a gâché du coup c'était ça où elle
était alors si je dis pas de bêtises
c'est à l'intérieur il ya une petite
détente qui devrait moins bien lotis
dans des tentes à l'intérieur en plus
parce que ça c'est tellement dur
donc c'était du 22 mai l'ancien en
dessous de shorts ouais le chemin des
courts noirs sympa belle trouvaille
baptiste
prêt pour le deuxième pistolet ouais
mais non
c'est un lycéen qui tantôt dit je suis
là ouais vélos
et mobylettes
oh
ah ça c'est un morceau de plaque d'égout
hu s'est remplie si toutes deux fous les
gars
imamura star est bien ici un
[Musique]
à la vie
ouais
bref c'est bon ça vient a dit devrait
débloquer un
deuxième
voie là haut une barre de fer
séverine attend
aussi lourd vas-y tu attends m'aider à
ses amis motos ouais
c'est du poids
delpech ces tissus des graisses
pas pourquoi mais ça c'est terrible et
tirer un mois tout ça va
qui c'est qui cette salle en offrant
une
[Musique]
belle page hunt est là quand j'étais
coincé tu m'as volé ma trouvaille du
coup mais bon y'a sa petite casserole au
à des cailloux dedans
elle en bon état en faïence ouais sympa
tu es content rasta tu pourras manger
des croquettes dedans
superbe à 3 et
wau jolie et prometteur jeu
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
où il ya du poids
aux
alors atteint saurais pas dire ce que
c'est
un genre de système hydraulique à un
morceau de defour le pinceau ouais ils
marchent en quoi
ce héros
et aux pièces assez dur en face des
longtemps
sa ferme de 1000 francs il me semble
sympa non
à
bidart
c'est des lumières à l'émirat qui
mettront l'épaule ouais sympa
ça va
tomber de vélo voilà alors là une idée
alors là je pense que c'est un outil
non
enfin en partie c'est lourd il me semble
qu'on a un petit coffre-fort ce serait
bien
j'ai ouï oui
il est évident et équipé par derrière
ouais petit coup de disques elle sur le
côté
est-ce qu'ils ont caché quelque chose
dedans
ron
ouais cherche les moules c'est qu'ils
ont tous sorti qua non vie des bombes un
super bel troyen
a du coffre et un code ouais c'est notre
seizième
à
dix sept films hausse et un chariot de
vieux
ces chariots pour les courses de mamie
ouais
ya peut-être des choses dedans plus qu'à
trouver la grand mère non non c'est vide
un peu toi non c'est non merci
bonne soirée
encore du franc ouais et peut-être que
le coffre qui contenait des france dont
la saison passée le procès de francs en
tout cas bientôt faire nuit à l'année à
temps
leurs vieilles 1960 ouais
ouais jolie alors ta poche
[Musique]
entre une moto non cadres ouais mais au
vélo ou en moto
[Musique]
mobylette à
hu
à temps
[Musique]
bien joué les gars alors qu'il vit dans
le solide et
mal tire un peu
bien d'un gars y'a
belpech ça voilà quand les abonnés z1
bas merci
à 12 on aurait gagné il aurait fallu
sort sur l'autre
c'est un peugeot du coup écrit qu'à part
du sang lors de pêche dessus là
il nous remerciera le pêcheur et son
épouse aussi
superbe sympa ouais à des mois sa peau
giuly scooter
chez paulo enfin ici officier n'a pas
fini la
bombe à la nuit commence à se lever
ouais alors la sortie de lampes
frontales de chez king lighting donc
comme vous pouvez le voir secteur plutôt
pas mal or on avait une question comment
est-ce qu'on recharge la lampe alors
recharge usb pas de piles donc pratique
vous pouvez mettre sur eux du coup
n'importe quel chargeur de téléphone
pour héberger sa sur l'ordi dans la
voiture donc c'est plutôt cool vous avez
plusieurs modes donc ici je suis sur le
mode grand-angle web plutôt sympa voilà
le grand angle de la lampe king lighting
éclairage à 260 degrés il me semble
ouais c'est ça plutôt cool vous avez
d'autres modes un mode ici un petit peu
moins puissant pour économiser la
batterie avec une autonomie de 5 à 8
heures avec ça donc ça rigole pas ouais
vous pouvez aussi faire un mode
précisions ici donc voilà typiquement
pour regarder les trouvailles ont plutôt
sympa aussi prêt à porter pour la
période c'était quoi ça ben je sais pas
mais c'est peut-être de la mobylette du
scooter peugeot hockey et vous avez le
mode mains libres
donc ici la lumière passe au bleu
ouvert aux verts halton hills me voilà
europe et a rallumé est un ami avec ton
point de vue d eux si vous souhaitez
vous équiper vous avez le code pêcheurs
20 donc il vous offre 20 % sur le site
de king lighting oui tout ça en
descriptions ouais bon bah t'as pratique
maintenant on pêche cas pratiques
passons à la pêche allez c'est parti
auger quelque chose
au un brûleur
sympa
aux appels aux intel bravo et autre
chose oh
ça c'est levier
alors oui c'est moi de voitures way you
lie
alors ta elle a pris charge
fatigué jolie mal troy
r'n'b une fourchette
la whey t'as vu j'ai vu tu as mangé avec
ce soir bon bah oui bien sûr merci
aux y avait du bruit leurs enfants tu as
entendu rasta marois a
touché quelque chose de gros
je m'éclaire
aux jolies boucles
c'est un bol de forme sympa
c'est la fonte ça tient droit comme ça
oh il ya du cuivre bah ça ça vous dit
tout tout petit mobile de cuivre au
milieu bien joué
par an pour la sortir ouais c'est la
misère à casser ce truc tu es pas pour
rien qu'ils ont jetés quoi
au couteau
donc le bois est vieux
c'est l'inox du coup ils conservaient ça
c'est du sang et anciens c'est peut-être
années 70 vraiment on voit le style
ouais la forme et c'est passé
ouais sympa moi je le garderai pour en
revenir au pistolet qui a été pêché
aujourd'hui donc il s'agit bien d'un
pistolet de salon donc ces pistolets de
salon étaient des armes qui ont été
fabriqués à partir de 1850 jusqu'en 1890
et qui était vraiment destiné à du tir
de précision et un usage récréatif d'où
le nom pistolet de salon d'ailleurs
puisque c'est des armes qui étaient
utilisés parfois pour tirer dans son
salon simplement en effet sa utilisent
des munitions qui sont tout petit donc
c'est du 22 shirts et des missions
encore plus petit que le 22 long rifle
ou alors du 6 mai est bosquet donc une
munition ancien tout petit aussi nous ce
qu'on est en train de faire c'est qu'on
est en train de restaurer cette arme là
qui bien sûr est classé en objets de
collection et donc en catégorie d bon
voilà on a beaucoup de difficultés à
débloquer le mécanisme il faut aussi
qu'on fabrique une nouvelle cross mais
en tout cas voilà c'est exactement ce
modèle là bien sûr la vidéo de
restauration sera postée sur la chaîne
donc si ce n'est pas déjà le cas
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner pour ne pas
la manquer
ouais aurait plutôt pas mal à ces lampes
franchement ouais ça on serait un peu
perdue là n'hésitez pas le code pêcheurs
20 et je me répète sur le site de king
lighting si jamais vous voulez vous
équiper d'une lampe frontale
bien sûr ces lampes frontales s'est pas
seulement pour la pêche à leyment vous
pouvez aussi faire n'importe quoi avec
et surtout de l'après pêche c'est qu'il
ya pas mal de pêcheurs qui nous suivent
ça c'est un coin de pêche nettoyer la
peau de pêche nettoyez vous pourrez
pêcher tranquillement
du fait que l'hymne et au talent pas
avec ton poignet oups je me disais mais
ça vient d'où ces trucs qui craignent un
meeting vraiment fort allez c'est parti
attend il reste encore un sachet avec
les tissus bon ben voilà cette vidéo de
poche allemand touche à sa fin donc de
très belles trouvailles encore une fois
de plus dans béziers c'est notre stock
favori du moment et un grand merci à
fabrice et aymeric qui nous ont
accompagnés pour cette pêche pour nous
avoir aidé à soulever le scooter on a
gagné beaucoup de temps